this week we will examine some more
advanced topics in the application of
Newton's laws of motion first we will
look at more examples of constrained
motion where the motion is forced to
obey some particular condition in
addition to Newton's laws of motion
these conditions usually specifies some
particular relationship between
coordinates of objects in the system we
are studying specifically we will
reexamine the case of objects suspended
with pulleys and ropes but with more
complex systems that we have discussed
previously the fact that the ropes have
fixed length will provide a constraint
condition relating the coordinates of
our various masses second we will
examine the case of forces acting on a
continuous extended mass distribution as
opposed to acting on discrete point
masses this will allow us to introduce a
powerful differential analysis technique
from calculus where we model continuous
mass distributions as made up of lots of
small discrete mass elements and then
examine the limiting case of
infinitesimally small elements to obtain
the continuous behavior this is a
technique that you will see applied over
and over again in physics and
engineering and in fact we will return
to it again later in this course our
specific example will be to study how
tension varies in a long massive rope
this is in contrast to the light
effectively massless rope still we
discussed previously finally we will
discuss velocity dependent forces that
is forces whose strength depends on the
velocity or some function of the
velocity of the mass being acted on the
most common example of this is resistive
forces or drag forces which are caused
by motion of a solid object through a
fluid like air or water that is the
example we will discuss this week
another example you may be aware of is
the magnetic force that acts on a
charged particle which depends upon the
velocity of the charged particle in all
three of these cases we will simply be
applying Newton's three laws of motion
but the situation's will require a more
sophisticated treatment than what has
gone before